في التطورات التي تشهدها السودان فدى
مراسل الجزيره باستخدام اسلحه ثقيله في
اشتباكات قرب المنطقه الصناعيه وحياي
يرميلا والحل الحله الجديده غرب الخرطوم
كما سمع دوي انفجارات في ام درمان وشهد
تصاعدا لاعمده الدخان وتحليق للطائرات
الحربيه في سماء مدن الخرطوم والخرطوم
بحري واندرمان
اعلن تحالف لجان المقاومه مجموعه الميثاق
فوريه لمدينه زالنجي وسط دارفور محاصره
تماما من قبل قوات الدعم السريع التي نصبت
عشرات نقاط التفتيش على الطرق التي تؤدي
للمدينه واضاف التحالف في بيان ان عشرات
القتل والجرح سقطوا في زالنجي واصفا
الاوضاع الانسانيه في المدينه
بالكارثيه واشار البيان الى توقف شبكات
الاتصالات والمرافق الصحيه تماما فضلا عن
نزوح اعداد كبيره من سكان المدينه
معنا من الخرطوم مراسلنا اسامه سيد احمد
اسامه الجديد هذا التوتر وتيرته في
العاصمه الخرطوم وما يجري فيزالنجي ايضا
في ظرف
قبل اكثر من ساعه من الان كان هناك خط
مستقيم هنا في الحكومه مستهدفه بعض
الاماكن التي يعتقد انها تجمعات لقوات
الدعم السريع في منطقه وهي المنطقه تقع
بمنطقه شرق النيل العاصمه السودانيه مع
تحليق مستمر وكثيف للطيران الحربي للجيش
السوداني كما سمعت الدوري اطلاق المضادات
الارضيه تابعه لقوات الدعم السريع في عدد
من المناطق المتفرقه
بالجنوب ووسط الخرطوم كذلك يبدو ان
التطورات الميداليه لهذا اليوم يغلب عليها
الهدوء وان كان هدوءا بالحذر في اغلب
الجبهات القتال ما بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع في هذه الحرب
المستمره وقاربت على دخول شهر الثاني ولم
تفلح لايقافها كل النداءات الداخليه
والدعوات الاقليميه والد كذلك يعني اعمده
الدخان لا تزال تتصاعد بكثافه منذ نحو
اكثر منذ نحو اسبوها وهي ما بقي من من اثر
الحريق الضخم والكبير الذي طال منطقه
المستودعات التي تحدث طبعا مخزون الغاز
والوقود وهو يقع جنوب الخرطوم وهو طبعا
احد اكبر مخازن الغاز والعقود بالبلاد
وهذه المنطقه تجاور مجمع اليرموك وهو احد
المؤسسات العسكريه التابعه لمنظومه
الصناعات الدفاعيه للجيش السوداني هل كانت
شهدت هذه المنطقه الشباكات عاليه قبل نحو
اسبوع
تساقم هذه المنطقه عدد من الاحياء السكنيه
امس طبعا كانت هناك انتباباكات وتبادل
عريس في اطلاق النار بشارع الوادي بندرمان
وهذه المنطقه دخلت مسرح المواجهات حديثا
لم تكن معهود فيها ان تشهد يعني
وكثافه او الاشكال الاشتباكات في مدينه
طبعا هي في ولايه وسط الدافور بحسب
المعلومات التي تعترف من هناك انها محاصره
بشكل كامل من قبل قوات الدعم السريع
يعني
وتثير المعلومات ايضا الى ان قوات الدعم
السريع ان تغلق هذه الثقله مخارج ومداخل
المدينه يعني اشاره المعلومات ايضا الى
سقوط عشرات القتلى والجرحى
ومنذ طبعا يعني اندلاع الحرب في هذه
المنطقه
اصبحت تعيشوا اوضاع ماساويه انسانيه في
الظروف وبالغه التعقيد خاصه في في ظل
انعدام الخدمات الاساسيه من مياه هو
كهرباء وكذلك
الخدمات الطبيه والسحل المساعدات الغذائيه
وعدم وجود المنظمات الانسانيه في هذه
المساله سيدي احمد كنت معنا من الخرطوم
شكرا جزيلا لك